part of the way in which African
Americans were kept as second-class
citizens in America was by denying them
access to guns I'm Tracy Oppenheimer
fries and TV and I'm here with Adam
Winkler author of gun fight the battle
over the right to bear arms in America
was a launching point what prompted you
to write gun fight well in 2008 when the
supreme court decided the Heller case I
got calls from so many reporters and
what does this mean for the future of
gun control this mean the end of gun
control laws as we know it and so I
wanted to tell the story the amazing
story of America's complicated history
with guns about the founding fathers
having gun laws that were more
restrictive than the NRA would like
today and sort of cast in a new light
the famed American gun culture and the
DC vs Heller case after it was resolved
what did that mean for gun owners well
it means that every gun control law now
has to pass constitutional muster has to
go through the courts and has to be
ruled to be constitutional by
solidifying the right to bear arms in
the American Constitution it provides a
way that we can sort of break the
political stalemate over guns and you
mentioned the NRA I know you said that
the NRA didn't want the Supreme Court to
make a decision even if it would be anti
gun control why would that be one of the
most interesting things about the Heller
case was the vehement opposition of the
NRA to the case ever being brought now
their stated reason was that they were
afraid of losing they didn't want the
supreme court to reject their view of
the Second Amendment especially this
supreme court with a majority of
conservative justices some of the
libertarian lawyers involved in the case
confided in me that they thought maybe
the NRA was also afraid of winning that
they thrive on crisis-driven fundraising
appeals that Warren gun owners the
government's coming to take your guns
you said in your book that gun controls
as much a part of American history
regarding guns as a Second Amendment is
what did you mean by that well we think
of gun control as a modern 20th century
invention but we've had gun control
since the founding fathers the founding
fathers had restrictive gun laws that in
part were race-based racially
discriminatory banning slaves were free
blacks from possessing guns this is one
of the most interesting things I found
in researching gunfight which was the
close connections
between gun-control historically and
racism part of the way in which
african-americans were kept as
second-class citizens in America was by
denying them access to guns if you could
talk about gun grabbers a little bit
what are they well the gun grabbers are
those on the Left who are seeking to get
rid of all the guns in America who deny
the existence of one of our oldest most
established constitutional rights
because they want to get rid of all the
guns and often they'll support silly and
ineffective laws that really have no
chance of reducing gun violence I liked
one of your quotes that you said
disarmament is no more likely to succeed
than prohibition or the war on drugs
could you talk a little bit about the
comparison between these reforms we
should learn from our past we've tried
through prohibition and the war on drugs
to get rid of things that are small easy
to conceal and that people love very
dearly and they've been terrible
failures I think if we tried to get rid
of all the guns in America it would
similarly be a failure and probably have
a lot of bad consequences as well
prohibition led to huge increases in
organized crime and criminal violence
the war on drugs has done pretty much
the same there's 280 million guns in
America they're not going anywhere one
thing I do like to point out when we
look internationally is that in America
we have high rates of gun ownership and
high rates of criminal violence there's
a lot of countries that are high rates
of gun ownership and low rates of
criminal violence Switzerland Israel
countries that have very low rates of
criminal violence I think America is a
violent Society not because of our guns
but because of our culture and yeah I
mean we all know that complete
disarmament is unrealistic so why do the
advocates keep pushing for it well and
then on the same time on the other side
we know that getting rid of gun control
entirely is unrealistic we want to have
laws that restrict the access of guns by
felons by people who don't have or
mentally ill by people who are drug
addicts I want to move the debate beyond
the extremes on both sides and recognize
that we have an individual right to bear
arms that many forms of gun control can
still be constitutional but we should
look carefully and closely at those laws
to make sure that they're effective
before we pass laws that in the end just
end up harassing lawful gun owners and
don't do anything to really reduce
criminal violence the more guns less
crime argument now do you think that
this is important to consider with going
control eyes one thing is crystal clear
we've had 30 years of liberalisation of
concealed carry laws and we've had 30
years of drastic reductions in criminal
violence I don't make the argument that
those things are necessarily connected
but one thing we certainly know is that
liberalizing access to guns has not led
to huge spikes and violence that many in
the gun control community suggested
would happen you talked about Ron Paul a
little bit and do you think he's had a
big impact well I don't think he's had a
huge impact but one of the great stories
about Ron Paul's involvement in this is
that the Heller case challenged a law
passed in nineteen seventy-six and this
law in DC band handguns and effectively
banned the use of long guns shotguns
rifles for self-defense and that
immediately sparked a protest by a young
first term congressman from Texas named
Ron Paul and it turns out he was
successful he got the law drafted he got
the law passed from both houses of
Congress got President Gerald Ford to
sign it however because of some drafting
ambiguities the DC government read the
law only to apply to future changes in
their gun laws and not to pass changes
in their gun laws and so they basically
just ignored that federal law well thank
you so much again for coming in fairies
on TV I'm Tracy Oppenheimer